Olá, meu nome é Sabrina Wallace, e meus pais faziam parte da Força Espacial em 1969.
Acontece que tem um lindo cristal em uma forma semelhante.
Agora, muitas pessoas gostam de dizer coisas que não necessariamente gostamos de inventar e ajudar as pessoas a entender coisas que são difíceis de entender porque, você sabe, todo mundo está ocupado agora se preparando para a guerra de drones, a guerra eletromagnética de drones.
Fizemos isso no Iraque e depois, pouco antes, e você sabe, o país vai entrar em guerra de uma forma ou de outra.
Quer seja ou não, você sabe, nosso próprio povo ou qualquer outra coisa, temos uma séria deficiência de aprendizado nos Estados Unidos.
Se foi projetado e projetado ou não.
Vou deixar outras pessoas falarem sobre isso.
O que vou fazer hoje é mostrar exatamente o que você precisa explicar aos seus filhos para que possamos evitar a revolução do estilo bucal.
Tenho certeza de que é o que eles estão realmente ficando bravos.
E vamos fazer isso com educação.
Então, estou começando.
Nós não somos.
Meu nome é Sabrina Wallace.
Eu sou filho de um Austin.
E meus familiares estão envolvidos em projetos negros, projetos de acesso especial da Seps.
Então, eu sou membro da BAIER e meu avô é Bernard Heinrichs aqui, e esse nome é Sr..
Ele se casou com Helen Harding, e Helen Harding está diretamente relacionada a Pius Levi.
Meu pai era Steven Garland Davis.
Minha mãe é Lynne Gene Scheer.
Ambos são secretos do Central Super.
Em 1969, trabalhando no Projeto Silêncio, Sou uma Criança Modificada devido à Experimentação para Aumento Humano da Fundação Menninger.
Agora, tudo isso significa que tenho cicatrizes que a maioria das pessoas não tem na arquitetura de John von Neumann.
Não é uma interface entre cérebro e máquina.
É massa corporal.
Isso é impossível.
E parece que de novo?
Estou aguentando.
Então, aqui está a lista de casamento dos meus pais.
OK.
Aqui estão os manifestos de voos do Arsenal de Edgewood para meu tio-avô.
65/70 Army Chemical, Fort Dietrich.
Para onde?
Texas.
Nova York, Coreia do Norte.
Só um não é bom o suficiente.
Eleanor Hall Ainda é para os três.
Provavelmente estou aqui, estive envolvido com os Projetos Mothman e com a construção de Veículos para Homens de Preto.
Agora, a interface para cicatrizes de John von Neumann está aqui embaixo.
Eu vejo um lá.
E, claro, estou mais velho agora, mas esse é o seu coração.
Ok, então esta é a interface corpo-máquina com um banco de dados subterrâneo chamado Next the longer, que é IBM.
Então, na minha aula de alemão no ensino médio, eu escrevi errado.
Nick caiu à direita ali.
OK.
Por que isso importa?
Porque se as pessoas disserem coisas assim, é melhor que elas possam te mostrar evidências, provas viáveis, ou então eu não as ouviria.
Ok, então aqui está um pouco mais de documentação e, em seguida, vamos começar com a discussão intelectual.
OK.
Então aqui está minha família e Garland aqui.
Meu avô, Garland Davis, fuzileiro naval da Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mamãe, hmm.
E primeiro, ele se casou com Elizabeth Kraft.
Mas acho que algo com o DNA não funcionou.
Então ele se casou com minha mãe.
Tia.
OK.
Então você trabalhou para uma empresa que era meus pais e meu tio-avô.
Oh, desculpe.
Eu esqueci uma coisa.
Meu tio, meu tio-avô é onde eu moro.
Então ele é.
Ele sempre foi uma das minhas pessoas favoritas.
É um homem muito gentil.
Oh, vá lá.
Desta vez, eu tinha tudo encaixado na história.
OK.
Ah.
Tão sulista.
Então, eu tenho uma história totalmente diferente da dos meus pais.
Nunca me disseram nada.
Nada Então eu cresci e queria isso.
E eles me disseram que nada existia, exceto o que você podia ver.
E eu queria saber o que é todo esse material eletromagnético?
Eu cresci nos anos oitenta, nos anos noventa.
Eu nasci em 1979 e, se você falasse sobre a aura, todo mundo o empurrava para um canto e exigia que você se juntasse ao grupo de leitores.
E eu estava sempre sentado lá, tipo, você percebe que é uma parte do corpo.
E eu gosto, Não, você é estúpido.
Você tem que ter uma religião.
Eu nunca percebi o que eu era.
Eu não sabia por que as pessoas agiam de forma tão estúpida, como por que você mentiria sobre uma parte do corpo?
No entanto, meus pais eram esquilos secretos.
São quatro níveis de aplicação da lei acima de qualquer coisa que os civis vejam.
E eles são os ex.
A elite secreta.
O que?
É um serviço secreto de elite.
E é basicamente isso.
Uma vez lá, isso é polícia secreta.
Agora, você tem que subir mais um nível.
Ok, agora eu tenho que subir mais um nível.
Eles estão falando sério.
Sim, eu tenho que subir mais um nível.
Certo.
Então, fui trabalhar para uma empresa de Louisville, Kentucky, chamada High Speed Access.
E foi aí que eles me enviaram meus papéis para trabalhar para eles verem ali mesmo.
Eles simplesmente pegaram o suor de seu velho adulto.
Esta é a volta ao espaço para nós.
O verdadeiro back-end deste país.
Fui um dos dois técnicos a conectar o estado de Wisconsin da conexão discada à banda larga.
Então, estou muito claro.
L-3 Harris ou C 24, todas as diferentes formas com as quais lidamos com todo tipo de inteligência, o programa PRISM da NSA, tudo isso incluindo pacotes de gramas de dados.
Engenharia de rede não é o mesmo que instalar um modem a cabo.
Eu tenho que trabalhar com o técnico da fábrica e o engenheiro da fábrica.
Não há ninguém contratando uma fábrica nisso.
E não havia ninguém contratado nessa posição além daquele que eu.
Sim, eu tinha 19 anos.
Então, para o turismo internacional, para que, à medida que continuo aqui, as pessoas realmente não tenham nada a me dizer, porque estou exatamente onde estou dizendo que estou.
Corpo inteiro.
Perdoe meu pé sujo.
Tudo bem, então, irmã.
Vamos ver.
Solicitei serviços técnicos, uma rede profissional de campus monitorada pela UW Whitewater, vários pacotes de software, incluindo muito ouro na rede Maps, HP vintage, visão aberta em breves interações com o snort.
As operações de segundo turno incluem o processamento de bancos de dados usando o PeopleSoft, oito roteadores e switches de codificação atualizados.
Trabalhe com o Visio para criar um mapa de fibra do treinamento iniciado no campus.
Para simplificar, é claro que um estado inteiro é como um pequeno pedaço.
Quando fui ao centro de operações de rede, Louisville, ou queria me tornar um desses consultores de rede na Omni Resources em Green Bay.
Problemas com conflitos no sistema operacional, problemas com estudantes, conflitos no Shock West.
A empresa proprietária desenvolveu software, auxiliou o Cisco Fixed Firewall Stuff Program Assistant do Departamento de Correções do País de Gales, Wisconsin, instalou e implementou o programa de rastreamento interno.
O Departamento de Manutenção de Instalações da Ethan Allen School for Boys Desenvolve bancos de dados e acesse e forneça uma orientação para a implementação da Oracle.
Solucione problemas de rede e desktop nos departamentos e seja um grande trabalho.
De outubro de 1999 a 22 de maio, a Charter Communications manteve uma atualização e ensinou e solucionou problemas de uma rede ISP composta por três Cisco Kong Comm 21 e a Bay Networks tinha cinco racks instalados e tinha na temporada.
A gerência da Colin Cable, responsável por relatar semanalmente e mensalmente, alguns testes de largura de banda e uso do circuito, devolução de modems a cabo, problemas de garantia ou reimplantação, cobertura de luz, área de responsabilidade de mais de 12.000 clientes, instalou e manteve servidores Cisco AC 5300 em sete pools separados, monitorou a largura de banda em roteadores Cisco 7200 configurados com atualizações para 9.000 clientes e gerencia as relações entre operadores de cabo e técnicos em Plainfield, Illinois, enquanto treina nova equipe nas áreas técnica e administrativa.
posições em janeiro de 2001.
Confira a lista de softwares e isso é algo permanentemente desativado em 2004 por estar deprimida por seu próprio governo.
Para fechar a porta, disse: Você ainda é telepático realizando projetos?
Sabe, talvez você não esteja, mas agora vai ser divertido.
Então, o que vamos fazer a partir daqui é dar um passeio pela realidade de hoje em 2022.
E primeiro, vamos ter uma pequena lição do passado.
No meu trabalho quando trabalhei na UW Whitewater.
Ela tem um enorme ímã embaixo dela em um satélite fixo de órbita terrestre baixa acima dela.
E durante os anos setenta, a UW Whitewater tinha um monte de software disponível para todos aqueles bancos de dados clandestinos de Nick Furlong, IBM e outros.
Eles estão no subsolo.
Então, isso não é um talvez isso seja uma certeza.
Tem a ver com resfriamento mais do que qualquer coisa.
Então, novamente, quando criança, eu cresci desenhando coisas assim: eles testaram a interface cérebro-cérebro para telepatia sintética.
E há muito tempo que as pessoas mentem sobre essa parte eletromagnética do corpo.
E agora estamos em crise em nosso país.
Isso é de 1993, e é assim que funcionam os layouts Bluetooth do Zigbee.
É assim que eles se parecem.
E é exatamente assim que eles processam nas telecomunicações.
E eu vou mostrar tudo isso para mim.
Mas eu gostaria de salientar que eles estavam testando em crianças.
Sim, é isso que nosso governo faz.
Os pais, meus pais, acabaram de te entregar.
Esse é o trabalho deles.
É uma implantação secreta para síncrona.
Não.
Desculpe, pessoal.
Não, eu volto a isso da mesma forma.
Então, essa jornada para mim realmente começou com a ação de um scanner infantil, que é só eu ter o controle de toda a minha fisiologia, em vez de ouvir as pessoas ao meu redor me contarem uma história contando como evitar que eu pudesse sentir meu próprio corpo.
E, crescendo a partir de 1979, sempre achei isso bizarro, incomum, mas eu não sabia.
Eu não sabia que o cerne da vigilância eram os biofilmes humanos.
E uma vez que eu fiz isso, não estava bem.
E minha família me fez ir embora por quase uma década porque eu nunca tinha permissão para dizer nada de Perch.
Chris São os anos de outono.
Em 2019, tive um encontro com um inglês chamado Ambulância, e no telefone o cara da ambulância disse: Leve-a para o heliporto, leve-a para o chalé, leve-a para a fazenda.
Agora estou perfeitamente salvo pelo governo.
Foi a primeira vez que chamei uma ambulância.
Eu não estava preparado para isso.
E então eu soube que os militares estavam me observando.
E então eu conheci um erro cometido por nossa Agência de Inteligência de Defesa por meio de meus pais.
Na verdade, não.
Estou aqui trabalhando para a Charter, mas sendo capaz de detectar radares e todos esses outros sinais eletromagnéticos.
Isso é natural.
O cachorro reage da mesma forma que eu.
Não dizemos isso às pessoas, a menos que você esteja no Corpo de Fuzileiros Navais para ter consciência situacional.
Agora, a Stingray and dirt Bikes usa essa mesma parte do corpo porque é eletromagnética.
E em 1953, o tio-avô trouxe para casa um monte de fotos e drones eletromagnéticos e 1953 e, novamente, mamãe e papai em 1969 trabalhando no Projeto Salus, que controla quase todos os estados moleculares que temos dentro e fora do corpo humano.
Agora, se você olhar para as células agora, elas lhe dirão logística e movimento e basicamente tudo internacionalmente por molécula.
E você diz, isso é impossível.
Isso porque você não conhece a nano Internet das Coisas, a Internet das Coisas industrial e que muitos desses sistemas de interface de máquinas existiam em 1958.
Então, por que você não contou às pessoas?
Quero dizer, Edgewood Arsenal.
Estamos testando em nossos próprios soldados.
Vietnã com meu avô novamente.
Temos drones eletromagnéticos em 1953.
O que está acontecendo?
Certo.
Então eu vim aqui para West Virginia e a estranheza com a ambulância e depois continua.
Mais estranheza, veículos desaparecendo.
Então, vou às livrarias e eles têm essa pergunta.
Oh, estamos planejando para o condado.
Sou proprietário de uma casa, então fui em frente e comecei a construir 60 coisas mais novas aqui em uma cidade de 200 pessoas.
Eles foram levados.
Parece estranho.
Hein.
Então, comecei a pesquisar seis pinos g lo e, vindo da engenharia de rede e da cibersegurança, é um dos meus lugares favoritos porque faço ambientes matemáticos e isso aconteceu porque tive que sub-conectar o back-end das forças espaciais a endereços de quatro pontos que foram colocados à venda na Flórida no ano passado a partir daí.
Realmente interessante.
Mas eu também descobri isso.
De qualquer forma, quando você era engenheiro de rede e estudava para seu associado de rede certificado pela Cisco na época, você precisava realmente criar uma sub-rede em binário porque não tínhamos endereços IP suficientes.
Então, sim, eu leio matemática binomial.
Era parte do meu trabalho anterior.
OK.
Então, quando se trata de segurança cibernética, esse é o tipo de coisa nesta primeira parte que está totalmente cheia de coisas chatas, como as camadas laterais, a internet e coisas assim.
Então, novamente, quando você precisa criar uma sub-rede e isolar seus clientes e está em dívida com certos milhares de pessoas e elas o culparão por perder $300.000 por minuto, na época são comunicações charter.
Então você tem que saber o que está fazendo e não pode estar errado.
400 mil em um minuto.
Sim, é um tipo de pressão que você está sofrendo em um trabalho como esse.
Lembre-se de que há apenas duas pessoas em todo o estado que podem lidar com esse equipamento.
Então você não pode sair de férias.
Você basicamente tem que fazer um programa de babá.
Sim.
Portanto, segurança de rede, 60% de rede de área pessoal baixa.
E ela vai usar máquina a máquina, o que significa que nenhum humano está envolvido em um veículo ad hoc.
Note, por exemplo, aqui está um atacante, aqui está um drone.
Agora, eu tenho alguns problemas.
Em primeiro lugar, você não pode interromper esse drone.
A declaração 3000.09 do Pentágono afirma há mais de 11 anos e você pode encontrá-la no CSR.
Por exemplo, o Pentágono, em maio deste ano de 2022, disse que acho que nossos comandantes em terra precisam ser capazes de ler o aprendizado de máquina.
Bem, claramente o comandante, o marido, especialmente o comandante, não compareceram ao Simpósio de Inteligência Artificial em 10 de setembro de 2020.
Se o comandante tivesse, ele saberia que esse não era um sistema nervoso digital de ponta a ponta sem humanos envolvidos, cito, no Projeto Selous.
O que aprendemos sobre a entrega do produto?
Dê a eles o código.
A plataforma Salus é usada pela NORTHCOM com atualizações para fornecedores.
O divisor de águas é que os novos protótipos neurais de produtos estão em desenvolvimento e estão aqui.
Então, o que?
Novo protótipo neural Synchro para iniciantes, o G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
O que é Fuzing é uma organização de fuzing focada em disponibilizar produtos para as pessoas que realmente os estão usando.
Em seguida, eles discutiram se seriam os serviços de rede hibridizados ou digitalizados da Amazon, e a Microsoft e a Amazon disseram, ou me deixariam ter um contrato com o governo.
OK.
Então ficou mais estranho para mim.
E enquanto eu ouvia, eles disseram serviços de rotulagem de dados.
E eu fico tipo, essa é uma grande curadoria de dados de banco de dados.
E estou pensando no que os clientes fornecedores e eu escrevemos: Este é o Departamento de Defesa.
Então, para isso, você pode ir até o início e diz que a equipe do Jake, quero dizer, a Comissão Conjunta de Inteligência Artificial, o papel deles é criar IA.
real e todos podem e devem implementar inteligência artificial em tudo o que fazem.
Clientes em todo o DOD.
Quais são seus clientes?
Veja isso.
Portanto, a Contrasting Tools está sob a égide da Tradewinds e o projeto Maven e eu cito conduítes quentes usando sensores inteligentes.
O Grupo de Trabalho Sem Fio Biosensors 82.1 5.5 Grupo de Trabalho Especializado em Redes de Sensores Sem Fio para os padrões internacionais de eletrônica e engenharia, desculpe-me, engenharia eletrônica e elétrica.
E o Project Maven usa Pathfinder e eu para ver você andar e pensar dentro de sua casa em tempo real.
E vamos citar o projeto MQ nine Tethered to ground.
Essa é a Diretriz 3000.09 do Departamento de Defesa, que afirmou novamente que é por isso que o comandante estava irritado porque ele disse: “Não podemos ouvir essas máquinas, não podemos decodificá-las por sua natureza e não conseguimos transmitir um sinal”.
E cito aqui no portão, precisamos tornar o sistema da Força Aérea da IBM mais coeso com todo o resto.
Vamos criar um sistema nervoso digital de ponta a ponta.
Precisamos refazer no Departamento de Defesa como conectar todas as plataformas da IBM.
O que eles controlam?
Plataformas para lésbicas, veículos autônomos.
Você quer dizer drones autônomos, tanques, Strykers normais, todo tipo de coisas.
Aviões, confira.
E quanto a qualquer outra coisa?
Absolutamente.
A Internet das Coisas Industrial é um bilhão que tem veículos autônomos e tudo é ar aliado.
Mas você achou que era só para a parte inteligente que deveria investigar a nova forma de engenharia de RF de salvar o dia, chamada Green Road.
Não é uma nova fibra especializada ao longo da rodovia interestadual.
Quando perguntado se você poderia usar um pouco de luz para mover o lado montanhoso que é o lugar dos monarcas e acesso especial ao Instituto Nacional de Ciência e Tecnologia Curtis para que o governo pague às pessoas, isso não é brincadeira.
Projetos negros, lembre-se de que eu realmente não pago 45 mil por um assento sanitário inteiro.
Não, eles não têm.
Mas você sabe o que?
Eles fazem as íris nojentas.
Para que as pessoas tenham uma pilha como essa, elas precisam inserir cinco códigos para esconder para onde vai todo o dinheiro, a alocação de recursos, a logística e o transporte, e depois a realocação das pessoas dos projetos de acesso especial e, em seguida, a realocação de quem está encarregado de protegê-las, rastreá-las, rastreá-las ou o Departamento de Defesa até uma lista para modificação de projetos de acesso especial.
Fica fora de controle e é tudo de código aberto, e você pode ler sobre isso e pesquisar no Google.
Então esse é o nosso problema aqui.
Então você quer me explicar, o que são esses biossensores e do que você está falando?
Um drone MQ nine Reaper.
Está ligado ao meu DNA.
O que está acontecendo?
E, a propósito, quem são seus clientes?
Na verdade.
Cibersegurança.
Sim.
Primeiro simpósio de Inteligência Artificial.
Eles disseram a eles que todos os humanos estão fora do caminho, então devo dizer que, de ponta a ponta, o sistema nervoso digital, para que essas plataformas conectadas aos humanos, saiam do processo e entrem em raciocínio, permitem que o gerente atual use diretamente células de crédito de ciência de dados e.
Desde que eu era criança.
Entrevistas de interface de máquina.
Bancos de dados quânticos Correlação de gerentes.
Agora, por que eles fariam isso?
Portanto, a nova rede de área pessoal de 60% usará seu corpo para rotear os dados.
E antes que você pense: Ah, não, eles nos diriam que isso foi feito em 2005.
Isso é o que é a rede de sensores sem fio.
Os biossensores são basicamente permanentes e vitalícios desde 2005 e, desde 2005, com Zigbee e Bluetooth, e é disso que eu reclamei antes, quando o mandei entrar, eu era apenas uma criança.
Por que o Zigbee, o Bluetooth e esses biossensores são exatamente assim?
Porque é assim que funciona.
Os padrões internacionais para engenharia eletrônica e elétrica usam uma rede de área corporal ampla e 82.1 5.6 Padrões eletrônicos para o grupo de trabalho sem fio Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
E esses são os quatro círculos de sua redação técnica sobre o que eles são capazes de fazer por meio de seu corpo.
E, como sempre, você sabe, não deveríamos ter mais paraplégicos e tudo mais.
Eles podem fazer suas mãos se moverem.
Eles monitoram a densidade do tecido muscular.
Eles podem fazer você falar.
Eles podem.
E eles sabem agora.
Eles monitoram todas essas coisas sem fio.
Como isso é possível?
Se seu corpo precisa de um dispositivo vestível ou está usando seu roteador ou está usando seu switch como se estivesse usando seu roteador ou usando outra coisa?
Eu queria saber, então eu descobri.
Com a nova cibersegurança aqui com a Stryker, ela tem que ser máquina a máquina, assim como o simpósio no DIA de Said.
O problema é que a autonomia é um N9 vazio preso ao seu DNA e esse DNA gera uma parte eletromagnética do corpo.
E ninguém sabe disso.
Eles chamam isso de aura, eles chamam isso de todo tipo de coisa.
Oh, são OVNIs.
Nós não sabemos.
Sim, nós temos.
Skunkworks, Raytheon.
Acabei de te mostrar a foto.
O pessoal dos drones pode trabalhar por mais de 40 anos e receber o pagamento de verdade, de verdade.
Bem.
Nós mantemos você no escuro.
Segurança cibernética, militar, você sabe, segurança nacional.
Oh, é UFO Skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Todo mundo sabe disso.
Eles são fornecedores.
Então, o que é tudo isso sobre registros psíquicos?
Cientistas.
Eles são inerentes ao tecido humano.
Então, havia um livro que eu costumava fazer meus alunos lerem quando eu ensinava sobre isso quando era criança.
Aqui está em 1996.
Este livro foi escrito.
É chamado de Psicologia Integral.
E lá dentro você vai encontrar o que eu acabei de dizer sobre telepatia, empatia, precognição, tudo isso.
É atribuído a certas áreas do cérebro.
Então, essas redes de sensores estão reduzidas à nanoescala?
Em seguida, eles o colocam em um software proprietário quando precisam escrever para Zigbee e Bluetooth para esses biossensores permanentes e, você sabe, 2.1, 5.4, eles são fixados permanentemente em seu corpo onde.
A partir das sincronizações de radiofrequência.
Há dois deles.
Eles vão retirar toda a energia eletromagnética, incluindo a potencialização de minerais, de sua corrente sanguínea bioquímica e a transduzirão porque seu campo eletromagnético aqui, que você achava inútil, não existia e todo mundo zombava de você.
Na verdade, ele transduz qualquer coisa eletromagneticamente.
Agora usamos rádio sintético.
Este é um rádio definido por software.
Telepatia sintética, só para agitar sua pele.
Um pouco transduzido eletromagneticamente para dentro e para fora, usando partes do seu próprio corpo.
Então, como você acha que eles estão acordados?
Dados do computador?
Da mesma forma.
Os biossensores são literalmente ímãs.
Eles são fixos e ajustados com voltagem.
Como usar o Wireless Working Group ADA 2.15.5.
E essa é a sua rede de área pessoal.
Essa também é sua rede de área pessoal.
Na minha opinião, como você pode ver aqui, os seis G Maupin podem ou não ter uma rede de área corporal para fins de roteamento de segurança.
Eles estão roteando seus dados através de seu tecido e eu cito uma troca de informações digitais usando a condutividade elétrica do corpo humano como uma rede de dados (rede de área corporal).
Então, por que não precisamos de um chip cerebral?
Porque você está sem fio há 6000 anos.
A medicina chinesa, os meridianos, os chakras, esses são pontos nodais em seu corpo, telemetria eletromagnética.
Então, os biossensores permanentes foram lançados para todo mundo aqui em 82.1, 5.4, e eles tinham que ser permanentes para Zigbee e Bluetooth, e é isso que os fornece.
E então, o medidor de grupo de trabalho sem fio 2.1, 5.5 cuida de todos os diferentes tipos de redes e, em seguida, coleta certos sensores de apenas alguns corpos, abre o caminho mais curto, primeiros protocolos de roteamento ou motivos de segurança.
Mas eles também, quando os criam com Zigbee e Bluetooth, precisam selecionar o tipo de tecido muscular.
Desde 2008, eles precisam selecionar o calor para que você não sinta o cheiro da morte.
E então eles trabalharam nisso até 2011, em 2013.
E agora eles têm cerca de 13 protocolos de roteamento diferentes, mas apenas cerca de três deles são criados para protegê-lo das informações que você obtém, roteando dados pelo seu corpo, que extrai minerais dos glóbulos vermelhos para fazer isso.
Agora, é um aviso muito pequeno de nível zero até que muitas empresas estejam obtendo essas estatísticas matematicamente ao mesmo tempo.
E aqui está o que parece.
Então, aqui em nosso pequeno exemplo, você também pode querer observar que esses dois são de seis, cada um com cinco nós saindo deles, foram rotulados aqui e um, dois, três, quatro, cinco.
Então, para cada pequeno ponto, você tem mais cinco e eles são todos acessíveis eletromagneticamente através da nuvem comercialmente com Zigbee e Bluetooth, o que, novamente, é, você sabe, 2.1, 5.4, porque se não fossem, eles não poderiam vender Zigbee e Bluetooth na parede.
Eles não poderiam ter usado a Alexa dessa forma.
Todas essas coisas diferentes se comunicam com essas redes de sensores, e todas são conduzidas por bancos de dados de inteligência artificial e estão todas interligadas.
Então, se você estiver sem fio e estiver no mesmo grupo de trabalho sem fio do seu telefone, que na verdade é 2.1.
Então, em uma ampla rede de área pessoal, eles estão roteando seus dados através de você.
Desde 2005, eu posso escrever um aplicativo para ele e depois jogar com você assim, porque eles aqui estão acessíveis desde 2005.
Você acha que as pessoas não tiveram tempo suficiente para comprar telepatia sintética, dispositivos vestíveis?
Está tudo escrito.
E se você não sabia como escrever um aplicativo não é difícil e o GitHub o estiliza com algo chamado linguagem de consulta estruturada, ei, o que é convidar você para o backend da Microsoft, Apache e WordPress e perguntar a todos: Olá, esse é o Hadoop do estilo.
Então, essas pessoas nos anos noventa, antes de isso ser lançado em 2005, e por essas pessoas quero dizer o esquilo secreto dos meus pais, a polícia secreta, tudo isso, de novo, para quem, novamente, Força Espacial desde 1969, inteligência de sinais, etc.
Ok, então eles têm algo chamado interface cérebro-cérebro, uma telepatia sintética e é acionada por frequência, ponto a ponto.
Sim.
E eles colocam um capacete na mesa e podem atravessar o tecido humano.
Novamente, essas coisas são monitoradas em tempo real.
Diga-nos se isso não foi ruim o suficiente.
Eles também incluem todos os bancos de dados de coleções que você vê listados aqui.
Então, a TV, todos os seus sentidos, coisas, radar, Doppler e, em seguida, as caixas de sujeira voam acima de sua cabeça e se comunicam com o software Stingray, que é escrito para departamentos individuais do xerife, dependendo do tipo de banco de dados que eles desejam assinar.
Então, o resultado é que aqui estão três corpos andando pela estrada.
Há dois corpos em uma casa.
Esses corpos agora estão sendo utilizados pelo mesmo motorista porque, por acaso, seus corpos têm a melhor segurança da máquina.
A máquina usa apenas esses critérios e eles são listados se você quiser ler a máquina, aprendendo a observar o pedido.
E então a chave para separar quantas vezes eles atingem o nó, quanto tempo eles esperam um atraso de 0,06 segundo.
E é o mesmo em cibersegurança para tudo.
Olá.
Adeus Intermitente.
Espere, fique.
E se você sabe alguma coisa sobre hackear dados com pacotes reais e não apenas coisas de nuvem corporativa definidas por software, ou seja, principalmente usando software, quero dizer, do lado do hardware, eles separam todo o pacote até a camada física de endereço Mac do seu corpo.
Esse é o problema em que estamos.
É por isso que vamos direto ao assunto.
Eles estão conectados à medula óssea.
E a forma como a Cisco McCann alimenta tudo ao seu redor na rede inteligente é quando você anda, quando dança e quando se move.
E essa é outra parte sobre a qual você pode ler em oito, 2.1, 5.5 e redes de área ampla 802.15.6.
Então, novamente, o problema que encontramos é que quando você tem três corpos andando pela estrada, esses dois agora estão disparando toneladas de sinais que indicam que cada nó é mais cinco.
Agora, todos esses sensores estão ficando loucos.
Essa pessoa aqui, a máquina seleciona essa pessoa aqui, o DNA, seu DNA, seu corpo.
É isso que cria o sinal seguro que o drone está usando para propagar seu DNA.
E é exatamente assim que funciona.
Então, para impedir que esse drone dispare qualquer coisa, você precisa impedir que seu DNA se propague.
Por que eles fariam isso?
Então, uma última vez.
Se você tiver azar e alguém for atingido por uma arma biológica.
Isso é transdução elétrica sobre o grupo de trabalho sem fio aberto de redes de área corporal ampla.
Portanto, não importa em que você acredita.
E isso nunca aconteceu.
Eles fizeram tudo isso aqui.
Vocês dois eram videntes.
E então, quando eles transduzem humanos e fazem testes reais, que são engenharia de tecidos sem fio e controle piezoelétrico total sem fio, mitigação neural para modulação comportamental.
Nós temos danos cerebrais.
Você quer dizer áreas muito sutis em nanoescala do seu cérebro para manter seu comportamento sob controle.
Em seguida, enviamos você para as pessoas e dizemos que a terapia cognitivo-comportamental o ajudará nas necessidades de programação de inteligência artificial.
Sabemos que se você disser isso repetidamente, você vai fazer isso.
Então, por que eles não consertariam seu ambiente epigenético?
Porque eles não estão interessados nisso.
Ou eles teriam contado essas coisas às pessoas há muito tempo.
Eles estavam estudando transporte e testavam as pessoas quanto à ciência de suas habilidades em bioinformática e genômica.
Uma vez que seu corpo não consegue mais transduzir esses sinais eletromagnéticos, isso não é natural, há muita energia na corrente sanguínea, nos ossos e no sistema vascular funcionando.
Eventualmente, enfraquece as veias, as artérias, a pele, e então você está com problemas.
Então você está fingindo se perder na floresta?
Você foi para a clandestinidade?
Estou brincando.
Então foi isso que eles fizeram.
Ninguém disse a verdade.
Stingray e a polícia foram encerradas em 1972.
Então, fui usado pelo chefe de polícia com meu cérebro ou, desculpe-me, com a interface corporal da minha máquina na época, porque eles ainda precisavam ter uma mesa de estudo com nano lipídio ou hidrogel para que pudessem passar e mostrá-la em um monitor.
Isso é o que todos esses guardas são.
Então, agora todo mundo está quieto desde 2005 e disponível comercialmente.
E, novamente, o novo padrão de segurança cibernética é uma rede de área corporal ampla que pode ou não estar envolvida em uma rede de área pessoal que pode ou não envolver seu iPad e todo o resto.
A segurança cibernética aqui, fevereiro de 2022, para a identidade digital aberta seis vezes roteamento e as ideias digitais feitas com seu telefone.
Isso mesmo.
Frequência e residência do seu quê?
Seu DNA gerou componentes eletromagnéticos sem fio acessíveis comercialmente desde 2005.
Eles nunca informam que seu médico não admitirá isso.
Você aprenderá.
Falaremos sobre isso.
E se você tentar.
Mas tire sarro de você.
Por quê?
Você não quer ter controle total sobre humanos e tê-los em controles remotos para fazê-los fazer o que você quiser?
Sem livre arbítrio, sem capacidade de pensar.
Eu te disse.
Mitigação neural com sutileza.
O que de novo?
Modificação de comportamento.
Mais uma vez.
Sinais vitais, respiração.
Fácil.
O monitoramento ACG monitora o aparelho auditivo de glicose.
Quais são os usos não médicos do que você está colocando no osso?
Porque quando o fazem, seus glóbulos vermelhos precisam operar de acordo com o roteamento e retirarão magneticamente esses minerais, desculpe-me, que estão no meu ombro, diretamente de sua corrente sanguínea.
Bem, dados de streaming de vídeo, transferência de arquivos, esportes, 3D, vídeo, coisas esquecidas, monitor.
E então, mais uma vez, você poderá fazer três coisas: aplicativos de entretenimento: relações públicas, jogos e redes sociais.
Começando a ver como o metaverso eletroceutica a Internet das Coisas, a Internet dos corpos, a Internet cibernética das Coisas.
Está tudo interligado dentro do seu cérebro aqui, aqui.
Então, quando tentei contar às pessoas como eu sou a partir de projetos de sangue, você entendeu essa parte do corpo e, se não começar a trabalhar com ela, começou a descobrir.
Isso é guerra de drones.
Você vai esperar, não é ninguém.
Então, o que você precisa fazer é entender que a única coisa que você tem agora é a fisiologia em primeiro lugar, que é admitir que é a parte do corpo.
Eles o condenaram à escravidão humana total e eles a têm.
É incrível que tudo seja feito no departamento de polícia, nos departamentos do xerife.
Como eu disse, eles terminaram em 1972, sendo capazes de falar uns com os outros com telepatia sintética e um monte de crianças pequenas.
E então, quando éramos adolescentes, aí veio o resto: 2013 foi quando eles realmente lançaram a interface de chip cerebral.
Profissionalmente, as pessoas ainda não sabem disso.
Eles ainda acham que você precisa de um chip real em seu cérebro.
Você não.
Basta comprar uma nano antena com a frequência certa para a ampla rede de área corporal.
Custa cerca de cem dólares e então você compra um dispositivo vestível de geração de telepatia sintética de $200 que simplesmente entra nos nervos cranianos para, sutilmente, permitir que você ouça todos os sinais ao seu redor que estão sendo projetados nessas redes.
Essas redes estão conectadas a tudo na Internet das Coisas, na Internet das Coisas industrial, na nano internet cibernética dos corpos, e zombam de seus corpos da Internet para elas.
Tipo, como se você não soubesse a especificidade, então você precisa, porque então eles disseram: Ah, mas é só em hospitais.
E eu digo: Não, não, não, não, não, não, não, não.
Isso é bobagem, quero dizer, quero dizer, isso é um projeto de engenheiro.
Por que você o deixaria apenas no hospital?
Quero dizer, nem funcionaria dessa forma.
É totalmente sem fio, via satélite, inclusive.
Então, naquele drone escolhe seu DNA porque o MQ nove está ligado a você.
Lembre-se de que acabei de dizer isso e vou dizer MQ nove.
Dez de setembro de 2020.
Inteligência Artificial Pentagon MQ nove amarrada ao solo Projeto Maven Projeto Pathfinder com detecção de objetos.
Isso mesmo.
Em uma área cognitiva do corpo, as redes estão ficando confusas porque usam algo chamado rede adversária e atacam você.
Porque eles estão assistindo.
Você pensa que, com esses comentários, é cognitivo para observar o radar cognitivo, você pensa em tempo real.
E aparece em uma pequena roupa minúscula e eles clicam em um botão.
Eles tiveram um ataque cardíaco e um derrame ou qualquer coisa que quiserem, qualquer molécula, qualquer estado que enfrentemos, está tudo disponível para eles desde 2005.
Oh, no mínimo.
Meus pais fizeram esse procedimento, então foi em 1969.
Todas as moléculas do planeta, em todos os lugares.
Então, como chegamos aqui?
Como tudo isso se concretizou?
Sem responsabilidade mental, sem falsidade, nada.
Nós apenas os deixamos escapar impunes primeiro.
Eles estavam sutilmente eletrocutando.
Muitas pessoas tinham fibromialgia, mas ninguém sabia.
Eu disse, um tumor é se você tem um tumor, mas não podemos encontrá-lo fisicamente.
É só que seu cérebro está agindo como se tivesse uma pseudo-convulsão.
Então, caramba, não sabemos por que você está tendo tantas convulsões.
Lúpus, doença de Lou Gehrig, uma doença autoimune de 80% do seu sistema imunológico está naquela parte invisível do corpo em 40 a 60% do seu sistema endócrino.
É por isso que todos os hormônios nunca podem ficar sob controle.
Você continua mexendo com a transdução elétrica da estrutura celular básica do seu maior órgão.
Vá lá, pessoal.
E então eles não o fazem.
Doenças.
Oh, eu não sei o que é isso.
Eles têm.
A Organização Mundial da Saúde admitiu que o câncer não é minha história para contar, e é por isso que a deixo em aberto.
Então, muitas pessoas já descobriram isso com o câncer.
Eles dizem: Espere, estou doente porque agora você quer que eu faça quimioterapia?
Tipo o quê?
E sim, então não o Sr..
Endo, mas agora estamos chegando à síndrome da morte súbita de adultos.
Nossa, não sabemos por quê.
E quando eles se movem demais e têm oxigênio transduzido nos glóbulos vermelhos, acontece que muito radar dos serviços de transporte da Amazon.
A segurança é muito importante apenas por parte das empresas comuns.
Talvez seja apenas uma empresa comum que está dragando geologia ou o topo de um conjunto rochoso ou qualquer outra coisa que esteja retirando do seu corpo para escanear a área.
Novamente, é apenas parte de um grupo de trabalho de sensores sem fio aqui do ATO, 2.1, 5.5 e ponto quatro.
Mas agora está usando seu corpo porque você está no, você sabe, 2.1, 5.6.
E para nossos propósitos, para isso, em vez do Stryker, isso é um satélite.
Ela precisa do seu corpo em oito ou 2,1, 5,6.
Esses são sensores permanentes de vida útil desde 2005, disponíveis comercialmente.
E o Departamento de Defesa está vendendo, por meio do banco de dados, acesso a você usando nosso mesmo censo, Doppler, calor e luz, onde você mora e com quem fala.
É por isso que toda a razão que me trouxe até aqui foi quando percebi que meu condado, quem quer que eu more perto, minha pequena cidade de 200 habitantes, está examinando minha corrente sanguínea.
Isso ainda está aberto e isso me assustou.
Eu segui o link e fiz a leitura em todo o país e, novamente, estamos em fevereiro de 2022 para o digital.
Eu pulei uma cerca geográfica pegando pessoas para que elas não pudessem deixar sua cerca geográfica.
Mas ninguém te disse que você estava sem fio porque eles não querem te dar o controle remoto do seu próprio corpo.
Então, o que você vai fazer quando o radar chegar até você e ela estiver pronta com seu DNA para acabar com você?
Porque essa é a declaração sobre armas autônomas letais que eu continuei lendo naquele livro didático da faculdade.
Sim.
Então você não consegue ouvir, certo?
Seu corpo não o ouvirá entrar, seja um drone ou um conduto de transporte.
No entanto, isso é uma luz no meu canal, An Odyssey.
Está cheio de sobreviventes da guerra eletromagnética, pessoas como eu, nas quais esse material foi testado e depois implementado na escala de governança industrial para a Agência de Inteligência de Defesa, a NRO ou quem quer que seja.
Temos que entender agora que você está sem tempo porque eles estão indo para a guerra.
E eles estão nisso desde 2005.
E, novamente, minha família estava aqui em 1969.
Então, aqui no meu canal, ensino prática de biofilme, ensino ofensiva e defesa.
A defensiva é ótima porque você está se abrindo para dentro de seu próprio campo e aprendendo a realmente ouvir e respirar.
Mas a prática ofensiva do biofilme surgiu na semana passada, e eu pelo menos sugiro que você a observe antes de experimentá-lo e antes de fazer qualquer coisa que esteja familiarizada com seu corpo novamente e corrija todas as coisas que eles lhe ensinaram de errado para que eles possam acessá-lo remotamente, tirar seu sistema imunológico, porque o que vai acontecer são as cargas de plasma.
E se você observar que 2030 fala sobre isso, aquelas cargas de plasma.
Sim, isso é verdade.
Parte eletromagnética do corpo, você vai sentir isso de qualquer maneira.
Mas se você tiver conhecimento prévio, não terá medo e estará melhor preparado para observar seu ambiente topologicamente epigeneticamente e realmente entender as pessoas que são cúmplices de todas essas coisas que são realmente más.
Eles dirão que seus biofilmes começam reais ou não falarão sobre isso.
E então, se eles estão envolvidos em cerca de dois terços, são os propósitos deste país que estão envolvidos.
Eles vão apenas fingir que isso não importa e que, oh, isso não pode me afetar.
Eu acredito que este é o centro da revolução.
Eles estão testando nosso país porque nossos jovens correm risco biológico dessas coisas e sabem como é fácil comprar esses 400 dólares, ter telepatia e afetar as pessoas em Hollywood.
Eles vêm fazendo isso há muito tempo.
Bem, agora eles estão dando um passo adiante com as tendências de engenharia de tecidos, a ampliação.
E eu disse às pessoas, elas vão transformar a parte inferior do seu braço em peixe.
Mas então eles dizem: Oh, não estamos juntos.
E agora está aqui.
Existem médicos que estão se oferecendo para mudar o DNA das pessoas e transformá-las em estados animais, etc.
Sim, sabemos que é nisso que ela desempenha um papel todos os dias.
Ok, então, primeiro passo, você tem que ser honesto sobre sua fisiologia.
Você tem uma parte invisível do corpo e todo mundo sabe, exceto você.
Isso é um problema.
Por quê?
Porque é o seu corpo que é importante.
O corpo inteiro instantaneamente.
Agora projete esse campo.
Esportes a vapor.
Isso foi completo.
Vamos dar uma olhada no viés que realmente parece ser energia eletromagnética, não é?
Você ouve aqueles drones chegando.
Você vai sentir isso.
Seu corpo naturalmente o faz.
Algore parece gostar dos pássaros.
Todas essas coisas destacam as linhas principais.
Os militares os usam há muito tempo.
Por que você não sabia?
Por que você não tem permissão para saber?
Primeiro passo É a parte do seu corpo.
Etapa dois: se reconciliar com Deus.
Oração por pessoas que são como uma.
Jesus.
Ok, bem, o que você quiser.
Fisiologia.
Primeiro.
É uma parte do corpo e fique bem com Deus.
Oração para que as pessoas representem todas as formas de amor.
Então pratique religiões, seja o que for.
Ok, os avisos estão separados.
Que tudo em que você acredita é o dever que te ama.
Saber que há algo maior lá fora do que você.
Isso é privado.
Isso é pessoal.
Sua alma, ser soberano em sua pele.
Super.
OK.
Então, para qualquer pessoa ter alguns ímãs com ajuste de voltagem, entregue-os à polícia e à vigilância secreta, sem médicos, sem nada.
Por quantos anos?
Então, de repente, depois que o projeto diz: Ouça, eu digo: Oh meu Deus, estamos com tantos problemas.
Gatos, cachorros e peixes dourados.
E foi aí que eu fiquei realmente falando sério este ano, em abril.
E eu disse, A cadela bolha, aqui estão suas veias e artérias.
Eles estão bem.
Tudo bem agora.
Eles não se esforçam muito, isso é.
Mas muito esforço.
Isso é.
Observe com atenção e depois veja a aparência da biosfera quando ela espera.
Torcido.
Condenado.
Você não está puxando o gatilho.
Você terá muita sorte se conseguir chegar até minha porta.
E, a propósito, precognição, novamente, no livro que mostrei, as aranhas comem com ela.
Então, por que você ainda está fingindo que não está na Agência de Inteligência de Defesa deles?
Bancos de dados do Pentágono com todos os sonhos que você tem e que sua precognição também é observada porque está em seu tecido.
É por isso que as aranhas comem com ele.
Da mesma forma com Algore.
É tudo natural e todo mundo sempre diz: Oh, eu amo estar na natureza.
Por que todos esses fios e coisas?
E em breve eles vão embora.
E a maioria das pessoas não sabia que tínhamos todo esse plasma atômico esfoliante e todo o resto.
Nós o tínhamos em 1800 e eles o mantiveram por 150 anos para que pudessem vender de volta seu sistema imunológico e prendê-lo.
Agora que eles têm, não temos seu biocombustível e a próxima guerra eletromagnética.
Você não sobreviverá.
É simples assim.
Então, suas chances agora e você não tem muito tempo.
1953.
O que você acha que eles têm agora?
Você.
E depois.